[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ça
vous regarde en direct toujours masqué
vous le savez mais pas moins ravi de
vous retrouver au sommaire ce soir le
top départ de la 5 g en france deux
opérateurs sur quatre ont déjà lancé
leur offre techniquement les antennes
seront activés dans les neuf villes
tests retenu un meilleur débit plus de
capacité mais pour quoi faire
at on vraiment besoin de cette nouvelle
technologie beaucoup de maires hésitent
à l'autoriser ont-ils raison d'attendre
question au coeur de notre grand débat
ce soir on parlera aussi de ces images
d'affrontements hier soir entre les
forces de l'ordre les manifestants
rarement un rassemblement aura réuni
autant de monde devant l'assemblée
nationale rassemblement contre la
proposition de loi dite sur la sécurité
globale et contre son article 24 qui
vise à interdire la diffusion
malveillante de vidage de policiers en
opération face à la fronde cet article
est il mort né
réponse avec nos invités dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission enfin
notre grand témoin ce soir s'échine à
recomposer une famille politique
disparates sur l'économie de marché sur
la laïcité cette famille est traversé
par différentes lignes de clivage se
rappelle se rassembler pour 2022
alors que les français plébiscitent ta
couleur le vert
julien bayou le nouveau patron des
écologistes est avec nous ce soir voilà
donc pour le programme s'est farci
hashtag sévère pour réagir tout de suite
place au débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir julien bayou son jeune âge vous
accueillir vous n'avez pas la tâche
facile je le disais vous devez faire
parler d'une seule voix les écologistes
vous êtes secrétaire nationale d'europe
écologie les verts depuis un an on va
parler de l'actualité de votre parti il
ya les régionales qui arrive vous êtes
candidat tête de liste en île de france
on parlera aussi votre stratégie à la
présidentielle début de la crise
sanitaire mais d'actualité ce soir c'est
la 5g c'est le top départ c'est pas
forcément pour tout de suite
immédiatement mais officiellement les
autorisations sont données et deux
opérateurs sur 4 je voulais 10 ont
d'ailleurs commencé à proposer aux
utilisateurs des offres qu'est ce qui va
changer il faut t'il accélérer la
couverture sur tout le territoire
aujourd'hui à neuf villes tests combien
vont coûter les forfaits ce qu'ils vont
augmenter bonsoir marie lebel soir merci
d'être là des députés en marche des
yvelines vice-présidente du groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée michel combeau
le directeur général de la fédération
française des télécoms autant dire les
opérateurs à nous rejoindre dans un
instant et bonsoir stéphane bonsoir bien
un bonsoir à tous les fans d'ac à skis à
mes côtés comme tous les soirs et oui
myriam tout comme tous les soirs qui va
ouvrir ce débat tout de suite avec son
billet d'actu si j'ai bien compris on y
va si j'ai bien compris ce soir stéphane
bas si j'ai bien compris myriam c'est
pas si facile de se faire un avis sur la
scène gérard pour tout vous dire moi au
départ la 5g
je voyais pas trop pourquoi s'en priver
là je ne me souvenais de la 3g quand
même qui nous a permis d'avoir des sms
des photos ça c'est plutôt cool
après il ya eu la 4g qui nous permet
d'être relié à tout moment presque doux
tout endroit internet ça aussi c'est
quand même plutôt cool donc la 5g je
sais pas trop ce que c'était mais je me
disais ça sera encore plus cool que la
3g la 4g donc pourquoi s'en priver et
alors c'est pas c'est pas prévu très
écolo que vous défendez la non non mais
alors désolé de vous décevoir moi je
suis un petit peu comme tout le monde
c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même une
grande majorité de français qui est
favorable à la 5g quand on leur pose la
question les sondages regarder
63% d'entre nous pensent que le
gouvernement devrait faciliter
l'installation de la 5g alors les
écologistes sont contre c'est vrai mais
alors il faut reconnaître que parfois
les écologistes donne le sentiment
d'être un peu
a priori contre ou hostiles tous tentent
de progrès technologiques alors
aujourd'hui bien sûr il se méfie de la
5g mais en 2013 souvenez vous il se
méfiait l'époque de la 4g moyen de
grenoble les écologistes était hostile
au déploiement de la 4g alors ce qui a
changé c'est que depuis 2013 à grenoble
ils ont élu un maire écologiste eric
piolle est ce qui a changé aussi c'est
que aujourd'hui eric piolle il n'est
plus contre la chaîne privée car la 4g
soit répandue sur le tout le territoire
que pour que tout le monde puisse en
bénéficier
et du coup pour ce qui de la 5g bas ça
on verra plus tard
est ce que c'est vraiment nécessaire on
n'en est même pas sûr donc mais pas le
seul à dire ça il y avait une
soixantaine d'élus qui avaient publié
une tribune début septembre dans le jdd
notamment des maires de très grandes
villes comme lyon bordeaux et marseille
est en fait on a l'impression que la vie
qu'on peut avoir chacun sur la salle j
sur la 5g est liée à notre opinion
politique
quand on pose la question selon quand on
fait les bébés des bars selon ce critère
voyez qu'il ya seulement deux parties où
une majorité de sympathisants ne sont
pas favorables à la 5g c'est la transe
insoumise et l'existant et vous alors
quel est votre point de vue votre
opinion alors curieusement moi ce qui
m'a fait un peu douter de
l'intérêt d'installer rapidement la 5g
ccni les écolos ni les insoumis c'est le
président de bouygues telecom bouygues
telecom il s'appelle olivier rosheim a
évoqué en juin devant une commission du
sénat et on lui a demandé mais alors est
ce que ça vaut vraiment le coup de
s'abonner à la 5g et de se payer un
nouveau téléphone
bah on écoute sa réponse à la porte pour
le client le fait qu'on fasse apparaître
1,5 au lieu du 4 et naturellement sur le
téléphone un client va dire que 5 s'est
mieux 4 c'est humain peut pas le
contester
est ce que ça change quelque chose pour
lui au quotidien coûtait cedrico a
répondu dans une interview il ya deux
jours pour dire ça va rien changer pour
le quotidien du consommateur parce
qu'effectivement ça va rien changer
incroyable alors ça n'avait rien changé
nous dit donc bloqué puis c'est pas tout
à fait faut quand même que je vous
explique
il est aussi crédit de 5 g au début ça
c'est que bouygues a pris du retard sur
l'installation de l'assemblée alors
expliquer pourquoi du goût pour
compenser ce quota il aimerait bien
qu'on freine la mise en oeuvre de la 5g
du coup il lâche pas ses coups contre
salah 5g et quand on lui demande si par
exemple ça peut avoir des conséquences
néfastes entre l'environnement bah
écoutez sa réponse la 5g permet
lorsqu'on transporte des datas de les
transporter avec moins d'énergie mais la
5g parce qu'elle augmente
considérablement les débits nous permet
d'avoir un usage beaucoup plus important
quand on a un usage beaucoup plus
important on transporte beaucoup plus de
data et quand on transporte beaucoup
plus apte à même si unitairement c'est
un poil moins cher c'est beaucoup plus
consommateurs que ce que c'était
précédemment
voilà vous venez de trouver un excellent
porte parole julien bayou le président
de bouygues défend donc le point de vue
des écolos comme quoi ça revient ce que
j'ai dit au départ c'est quand même pas
si facile de se faire à un point de vue
sur la ceinture puisque tout le monde a
l'air d'être dans le camp on l'attend
pas forcément
alors pourquoi pas prendre un peu plus
de temps pour réfléchir avant de la
mettre en oeuvre c'est des ministres
l'avait déjà réclamé en juillet dans le
jdd on voyait que le ministre de la
santé et le ministre de l'ecologie avait
écrit premier ministre lui dire on
pourrait peut-être attendre un peu avant
la mise en oeuvre de la cngr ci
ministres eux mêmes l'ont réclamé en
juillet forcément on se pose la question
est ce que finalement il faudrait pas
respecté un moratoire sur la 5g attendre
le résultat d'études sanitaires avant de
lancer son développement alors c'est la
grande question est ce que voudraient
n'auraient pas pu mieux dire et je me
réjouis finalement qu'on n'est plus
publié cette tribune
quitte à passer pour des anti progrès je
me réjouis qu'on ait pu transposer cette
tribune et parce que au moins ça suscite
le débat
vraiment vous voyez vous avez résumé
j'aurai beaucoup à redire sur les
arguments pour les arguments contre
enfin en parler vous avez résumé la
difficulté du sujet et nous disons
qu'elle urgence quelle urgence à se
précipiter
quand lançait salah et l'ademe ont
envahi derra lambiel étude nommée julien
vont publier des études analysées
s'éclairer à l'est la migrante 2021
pourquoi se précipiter
tout simplement alors on a tout fait
très confiant c'est de voir dérouler
c'est vrai que la grande question c'est
au fond il ya une agence nationale qui a
été mandaté pour rendre un rapport
elle a donné un rapport préliminaire
pour dire c'est trop tôt n'a pas des
éléments on va rendre un rapport complet
à la fin de l'année 2021 merci spécial
et on vous dira si oui ou non c'est
nocif c'est dangereux pour la santé
honnêtement pourquoi pourquoi le
gouvernement laisse l'arcep l'autorité
de régulation ouvrir les vannes alors
que légitimement on pourrait se dire on
attend de savoir
il ya un premier rapport qui a déjà été
rendue le 15 septembre dernier sur le
développement sanitaire de la 5g il ya
aussi des études qui ont été menées
ailleurs dans le monde et qui ne tendent
pas pour l'instant à prouver qu'il y ait
des conséquences sanitaires et puis moi
je crois qu'il ya aussi un enjeu qui est
pas un enjeu sanitaire mais qui est
aussi un enjeu de compétitivité moi je
remercie le président de quick de panne
ou plus simplement prendre les français
un peu pour des neuneus et se dire c'est
vachement mieux d'avoir un 5 4 sur son
téléphone
il ya aussi pour nos entreprises pour un
certain nombre de secteurs je pense au
télétravail à la télémédecine à
l'éducation quand on traverse des crises
comme celle ci qui montre aussi toute
l'importance d'avoir une bonne connexion
et un débit important de data qui permet
en fait finalement 2
d'être connecté au reste du pays bonsoir
michel combeau bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous succéder à stéphane blakowski
pour des raisons je le précise de place
et de nombre de places possibles en ces
temps de crise sanitaire soyez le
bienvenu
vous êtes le secrétaire le directeur
général de la fédération française des
télécoms qui représente je le disais les
les opérateurs de téléphonie
expliquez-nous déjà juste pour bien
comprendre les opérateurs sont autorisés
aujourd'hui officiellement mais il va
falloir encore attendre un tout petit
peu il ya encore quelques petites
autorisations à obtenir avant de pouvoir
pour ceux qui ont un téléphone
compatible bénéficié de 7,5 gc ca oui le
gouvernement via leur sait pas donner
les fréquences en tout cas attribuer les
fréquences aux opérateurs à l'issue d'un
processus d'enchères qui rappelons le a
permis à l'état de récolter 2 8
milliards d'euros sur sur ces fréquences
a donc les opérateurs la faune les
dernières préparations techniques font
aussi je dirais préparant leurs plans
commerciaux pour le lancement de la
saint jacques est un vrai talent cement
progressif on le rappelle c'est
indépendant pour réussir qui sera fait
sur plusieurs années l'objectif c'est
30% d'antenne migrer en 5j l'horizon
2025 sans récifs d'abord sur d'annoncés
sur le rappel il y aura un quart du
déploiement qui sera fait ou devenir
obligatoire en zone rurale et toute
entreprise qu'elle soit à paris en zone
urbaine ou en zone rurale pourra
demander à être raccordé y compris si
elle est au fin fond d'une zone rurale
c'est donc un deux un développement qui
sera centré sur les usages et les
besoins des acteurs vaut il faut
l'autorisation des marques même dans
chaque ville 1 on le rappelle les maires
sont tenus informés des déploiements via
ce fameux dossier d'information du maire
qui est remis de manière obligatoire par
ascendant au père at her avant
l'allumage des sites et bien entendu les
maires approuve au regard du droit de
l'urbanisme l'installation des antennes
des pylônes des mâts en fonction de la
configuration du réseau
alors pour bien comprendre les choses se
passent la parole julien bayou c'est
promis débit plus rapide 100 fois plus
rapides
une attente une attente / 20 100 fois
plus d'objets connectés que va apporter
concrètement la 5g
y at il des risques on a commencé à les
évoquer sur la santé sur l'environnement
les clés pour comprendre avec clément
permis
[Musique]
après la 3g et la 4g voici la 5g la
cinquième génération des réseaux de
téléphonie mobile déjà présente dans une
vingtaine de pays elle débarque
désormais en france mais au fait
qu'est-ce que la 5g va apporter
alors vous allez avoir une vitesse de
connexion internet sur votre smartphone
qui va être dix fois plus rapide que la
4g mais aussi quand vous allez envoyer
et recevoir des informations
il va y avoir dix fois moins de latence
et enfin pour les utilisateurs en fait
quand vous allez vous connectez vous
allez très nombreux dans un lieu comme
un stade de foot ou un concert vous
allez avoir beaucoup moins deux
phénomènes de congestion des réseaux
parce que le réseau va avoir dix fois
plus de capacité à terme tous les
opérateurs proposeront la 5g mais seul
orange et bouygues s'y met dès
aujourd'hui de façon limitée seuls les
utilisateurs ayant souscrit une offre
spécifique pourront y accéder est dans
une zone restreinte de neuf grandes
villes françaises
le vrai décollage de la 5g en france
c'est plutôt pour le deuxième trimestre
2000 21 mai au delà des opérateurs il ya
ceux qui les équipent le champion
mondial c'est du chinois huawei un géant
controversé il est soupçonné uniquement
parce qu'ils les chinois en fait
huawei est fourni du matériel aux
opérateurs depuis plusieurs décennies en
france on n'a jamais constaté problème
mais par principe et dans le doute
dans le cas où un jour il pour le
gouvernement chinois pourrait utiliser
way pour espionner de communication ou
même les interrompre la france a préféré
prendre un décret et elle impose
maintenant aux opérateurs de demander
une autorisation avant d'installer une
antenne est bien entendu évidemment une
antenne huawei alors on sait comment ça
va se profiler il ya certaines enseignes
qui vont être interdites sur le
territoire dans des lieux qui sont
plutôt sensible et pour les autres
antennes huawei ça va être une durée
limitée l'arrivée de la 5g pose enfin la
question de ses effets sur la santé
aujourd'hui aucune étude scientifique
n'a prouvé que les ondes
électromagnétiques sont dangereuses
si des limites de puissance sont bien
respectées le déploiement de la 5g comme
tous les réseaux et soumis aux seuils
d'exposition maximal et à des
contraintes réglementaires
julien bayou pour vous le principal
problème de la 5
quel est il ah bon il y en a plusieurs
il ya d'abord l'aspect démocratique
c'est à dire que emmanuel macron en
juillet c'est pas loin en juillet
s'était engagé à reprendre sans filtre
les propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat dont le
moratoire sur la 5g c'est pas anodin le
président il dit un jour blanc le
lendemain noir si c'est valable pour
tous en fait il ya plus vraiment de
démocratie donc il ya cet aspect tout
simplement démocratique deuxième aspect
environnemental qui a été très peu
abordée va se discuter avec le président
d'ericsson
il nous disait à terme ces 20 milliards
d'objets connectés et ses fameux effet
rebond c'est à dire que certes ça
consomme moins d'énergie pour le même
usage
mais vous avez un usage qui est
démultipliée on l'a vu un 3g 4g
on est passé de petites vidéos à des
grosses vidéos hd et donc une
consommation est forcément un mauvais
parce qu'il ya aussi des usages très
énervé par pour les transports par
exemple on peut ré-imaginer la voiture
autonome imaginer des villes connectés
je les remets le x90 pour lui mais le
problème c'est qu'il vous faut une
couverture à 200%
si on s'y entend le télémédecine par
l'entité d'art des opérations de
médecine à distance
c'est pas une antenne qui vous faut
c'est une couverture à 200% pour être
parfaitement sur paris pour la voiture
autonome
or vous venez de nous dire que la la
couverture sera au mieux de 30% dans
cinq ans donc qu'est l'urgence l'an
quand on revient à la notion d'urgence
et a signé peut-être un redémarrage à
mme et m
et peut-être même et peut-être même de
d'abord et ça c'est une question
d'égalité des territoires
d'abord finir la couverture internet
pour le petit nombre n'est quand même
pas anodin de personnes qui n'ont pas
accès à internet d'après quasi vous
parliez de confinement marine avec
aujourd'hui effectivement pour les
personnes qui sont confinés et qui n'ont
pas accès à la téléconsultation qui
peuvent pas avoir internet pour payer
leurs impôts ou celle de nos familles
c'est pas la 5g qu'il faut c'est la
donnée par la fracture ni les derniers
éléments nouveaux a argumenté en titre
est passé sous silence c'est l'aspect
géostratégique et là encore si la chine
mais la chine ou les états unis
parce que pour le coup nous pourrions
travailler une logique de filière
européenne avec ericsson et nokia
notamment ça ça pourrait être
intéressant de donner les moyens
à terme de rattraper notre retard mais
ça passerait par exemple par un
protectionnisme vert et décidé de les
soutenir eux les autres au maire met à
l'honneur les arguments il ya beaucoup
de choses d'abord sur la fracture
numérique et c'est vrai qu'on est en
plein confinement ceux qui souffrent le
plus aujourd'hui ce sont ceux qui vivent
dans les zones rurales isolées les zones
blanches pour eux on se dit mais il est
lunaire ce débat sur la grille pourquoi
on n'essaye pas d'abord de réduire cette
fracture et on verra après c'est un plan
je crois que c'est un bien sûr on en est
tous rendus compte que le confinement
ici par exemple à l'assemblée les
collègues qui sont dans les zones très
rurales avaient parfois plus de
difficultés effectivement à se connecter
mais il faut quand même dire ce qui est
à dire depuis trois ans c'est pas une
initiative du gouvernement mais le
gouvernement l'a largement accéléré
notamment avec le new deal sur sur le
numérique le déploiement de la 4g sur
l'ensemble du territoire est aujourd'hui
un excès à l'autre 96 105 aujourd'hui à
96 % de couverture du territoire par la
4g ça n'exclut pas qu'il reste quelques
points de zones blanches mais il ya une
vraie dynamique a été mise en oeuvre par
ce gouvernement justement pour résoudre
ces questions dans la question
démocratique
cette convention citoyenne on auquel
tient tellement le président à
l'entendre a demandé un moratoire
est-ce qu'on s'assoit tu déjà quand même
je mets un petit bémol ce qu'ils aient
julien bayou sur la question
démocratique
à un moment les la démocratie c'est
aussi ceux qui ont été élus c'est aussi
les représentants du peuple
ce sont les parlementaires moi je dis
vite c'est-à-dire mention mais ces
conventions elle est très bien j'ai
écouté un intégralité les comptes rendus
des débats les décisions qui était prise
je trouve que c'était un exercice très
intéressant mais il n'empêche que
il y aura ensuite un
des discussions qui auront lieu à
l'assemblée nationale avec notamment
et parce que c'est aussi le rôle des
parlementaires une capacité à faire
évoluer les décisions qui sont prises
par la convention citoyenne d'ailleurs
n'ont pas mal maîtrisé la mise au bois
mais en fait ça il a 10 centilitres de
jamaïque on filtre c'est soit pour aller
plus loin soit aussi pour prendre en
compte un certain nombre d'enjeux
moi je crois que sur ce débat de la 5g
vous parlez de démocratie l'important
c'est quoi c'est d'informer c'est de
pouvoir en discuter vous avez raison
c'est intéressant finalement d'avoir
cette tribune qui permet de lancer le
débat sur le sujet fait faire de la
pédagogie faire de la pédagogie à dire
qu'il ya forcément quelque chose de raté
parce que même si 60% sont sont d'accord
on voit qu'il a une très grande défiance
dans le pays sur l'a5 j'ai bien plus
qu'ailleurs et pardon la défiance elle
est aussi quand on a des discours et je
suis désolé de certains de nos
responsables politiques à un moment on
dise on ne peut absolument pas de la 4g
c'est horrible c'est dangereux pour
votre santé et qu'ils avaient été
adoptées on peut très bien le faire pour
les ouvriers gagnent favorable à ce que
la commission nationale du débat public
organisent ce débat parce que quand
c'est vous moi et vous vous avez intérêt
dans la sphère vous vous êtes bonne
soldate de votre majorité
vous vous n'êtes pas excusez moi
outillés c'est pas votre goût je le
reconnais très simplement je pose des
question j'ai évidemment donc la
commission nationale du débat public
c'est son rôle
organiser des débats pour les
investissements qui nous engage pour des
décennies
nous réclamons voyez on dit pas anti
anti andy andy organisons ce débat
faisons le organisé par une instance
dont c'est le boulot c'est même aller au
delà puisque la convention citoyenne
pour le film a dit moratoire tant qu'on
n'a pas les études et si vous la tribune
du récit moratoire c'est le moratoire
tant qu'on n'a pas fait d'études j'avais
lu vous l'avez lu la tribune il ya deux
étudiants viennent deux études qui
doivent sortir de l'ansès et de la dden
et ça coïncide à mi 2021 pour ça que
nous lui disons on est en plein
confinement est ce que l'urgence
aujourd'hui alors qu'on va atteindre 10
millions de pauvres il ya toujours des
zones blanches c'est de foncer sur la 5g
voyez dans ça comprend pas mais on le
regarde beaucoup et j'ai trouvé que
c'était un peu le biais peut-être de
certaines des interventions qui a été
fait c'est à dire de dire on regarde ça
du point de vue du consommateur final
vous
deux mois de notre utilisation
personnelle mais de quoi on parle en
réalité quand on parle du premier
déploiement de l'assemblée
on parle de ce qui va s'adresser à nos
entreprises de ce qui va leur permettre
de les rendre plus compétitives vous
parliez de la pollution vous parliez des
conséquences mais moi je crois aussi que
c'est des outils qui permettent
davantage de réguler et d'organiser des
villes d'avoir un impact sur les flux
d'avoir un impact sur la gestion des
trafics et par exemple moi j'ai été
visité il ya de ça deux ans maintenant
le port de hambourg
et bien je peux vous dire que dans la
régulation des flux les flux de camions
qui vont chercher des marchandises au
port de hambourg
eh ben ils ont fait des progrès
phénoménaux quand même je crois pas je
dois bien dans le cadre est de regarder
comment ils font bon alors on va pas
vous mettre d'accord puisque de toute
façon on voit bien que le gouvernement
avance donc le gouvernement avance alary
s'est pas donnée c'est autoriser des
tribus m'ennuyer oui absolument mais
mais mais ça permet de montrer des
lignes de clivage sur la question de la
santé
on attend donc le rapport final de l'âne
cesse michel combeau il ya d'autres pays
qui sont passés est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
études dans le monde qui ont permis de
montrer que ça n'était pas nocif
enfin il faut le rappeler si comme des
fréquences qui sont utilisés depuis plus
de 20 ans en france et dans le monde
l'ensemble des études dans les autres
pays n'ont pas conclu n'ont conclu aucun
danger sur la santé c'est dans ce cadre
là il faut rappeler en france qu'on a le
cas de l'un des plus sûrs et l'un des
plus détaillée en matière de fréquence
et de santé avec des mesures avec des
engagements sur des valeurs d'intention
avec un comité de dialogue on ça fait
plus de deux ans et demi qu'on parle de
5 g avec les acteurs de la société
civile avec les associations d'élus
il ya eu de nombreuses concessions
public j'ai lu que plus le débit était
élevé 5 g - la pénétration des maisons
je pars sans vous rendre dans la peau
était important autrement dit s'il
fallait graduée c'est moins dangereux
que pourrait l'être la 4g c'est vrai
c'est faux nom près sa célébrissime ans
à se dépenser un peu technique je pense
intéressement au moins - les usagers se
sont un ballack de feu les ondes et des
antennes oui mais ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la de la 5g fondamentalement
ce n'est pas différent de la 4g ce sont
des ondes qui sont qui sont émises et
d'amandes de ces fameuses bandes qu'il
va utiliser par les opérateurs sont des
ventes qui sont aussi utilisés dès
maintenant qui était utilisé avec
d'autres technologies donc les paquets
technologiques vous utilisez
les opérateurs se sont des nouvelles
antennes en passant sont des gens
intelligents sont ce sont les anciennes
ce soir ce sont des antennes qui
émettent des ondes la 5g son grand
avantage c'est qu'elle va cibler là où
elle envoie les ondes et pas uniquement
arrosé comme pour la cage et elle va
permettre aussi de s'étendre à s'allumer
expliquez-nous je suis un peu comme dans
une voiture sans téléphone sans une
antenne et marie vaillant valdôtaine
salut mais par contre si je ne
communique pas en 5 j n'y a pas de de
clion 5g autour de l'antenne n'aimez pas
et je ne recevrait aucune ombre 5g si je
suis sur une antenne nouvelle
effectivement cas plus économe en ondes
que les anciennes technologies c'est
aussi l'enjeu pour nous c'est de
moderniser au fur et à mesure notre
nouveau réseau ans c'était le cas avec
la fibre pour l'adsl la saine gestion
immobilia sont progressives de nos
réseaux et forcément un coût pour les
opérateurs
oui il ya un coût mais fort peu qu'on
investit près 10 milliards d'euros par
an dans nos réseaux pour les développer
les maintenir et les mettre à jour la
saint-gilles 20 s'inscrire dans ce
mouvement là il ya un coût
supplémentaire 5 g qui va se répercuter
j'imagine sur les fonctions dans les
forfaits
mais changer de portable il faut changer
de forfait mais mais sa façon il faut il
faut rappeler que les gens changent déjà
de portables 5 g ou ou pas s'engager ils
sont toujours friands des dernières
innovations que les métiers d'opérateurs
s'est investi les milliards d'euros par
an on investit par ailleurs dans les
zones rurales sur le plan spécifique
d'une audi mobile pour la 4g de zones
rurales 3 milliards d'euros dernière
spéciale du consumérisme téléphonique
télécom de toute façon et on ne sait pas
il n'aura pas plus oui mais c'est de la
faute des personnes d'usagé c'est un peu
facile à regarder ce téléphone il a
trois ans et demi ça est presque un
record effectivement moi j'aimerais
qu'ils puissent durer plus longtemps si
demain finalement il faut changer de
téléphone ce n'est pas de mon fait
il ya quand même apple qui a été mis en
cause par ce que il ralentissait la
vitesse de ses iphone quand ils
augmentaient le canton nouveaux
opérateurs
un système opérateurs sortez donc à
cette notion d'obsolescence programmée
que vous ne pouvez pas balayer d'un
revers de main les gens le on
logiciels matériels ou effet de mode et
imaginer que là on parle des téléphones
mais demain ça sera également valable
pour les 20 milliards d'objets connectés
qui sont autant de monde émission
évidemment de terres rares
encore une fois nous le droit sibilité
technologiques aussi très important
person reconnaître de brosses à dents
connectés connectés je voulais terminer
par sa sueur sur la médecine surtout ce
que les technologies de pointe mais je
voudrais juste non bien sûr le prix jean
des remords quand même que je m'habille
veulent savoir s'il faut refaire va
augmenter mais qu'est ce qui va se
passer vous avez quatre opérateurs mais
je m'attends free on sait qu'orange quoi
ça va être un peu plus cher françois
on a des prix les plus bas moi j'ai pas
commenter petits commerçants de chacun
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la
france alors des prix les plus bas du
monde en matière téléphonie mobile et
qu'après il y aura forcément
différenciation en fonction de la
quantité de négoce est proposée à la 4g
au même prix que la 3g
oui mais après ça elle semble avoir ça
c'est son positionnement on verra
comment les opérateurs
ils vont enfin après sanji 4g c'est un
faux débat c'est le nombre de données et
votre débit en fonction de ça vous
paierez un forfait en fonction d'eux
devrait être un peu moins cher première
année mais ça augmentera plus tard après
seul regret je voudrais qu'on parle
parce que le temps file sur sur 7,5 g
qui nous fait du bien parce qu'il ya
quand même des choses qui sont
incroyables des mobilités plus sûr on en
a parlé
la logistique plus fluide on a parlé des
ports les ports internationaux doté de 5
g pour gérer les flux de marchandises
des progrès immenses en matière de
télémédecine exemple un chirurgien peut
poser un implant dans le cerveau d'un
malade atteint de parkinson dans une
ville chinoise sur un patient qui à 3000
km à pékin plus loin c'est pas c'est pas
rien un agriculteur ça va vous
intéresser
pour une agriculture plus préventive
avec des fermes expérimentales des
vaches équipés de koné 5 g pour prévenir
la propagation des épidémies
mais est ce que c'est ça qu'on veut en
fait vient vraiment enfin le pdg
d'ericsson me parlait progresse assez
des progrès pour pour le bien de lui
disais on peut faire des camions
autonome et du coup les serrés les uns
derrière les autres et non dim
mais pourquoi vous voulez développer
nombre de camions voyez cet aspect de
technophiles i ou ii quand on appelle ça
de techno solutio nisme sur cet aspect
de télémédecine moi j'insiste on nous
dit on va déployer la 5g sur tout le
territoire et pour toute la population
alors que pour ses aspects de
télémédecine et bien
il faudra une couverture à 200% donc en
fait je crois que personne n'est dupe la
5g ça ça d'abord et en premier lieu pour
les centres villes denses pour les
grandes coeur de métropole à paris à
lyon à marseille
et tant mieux pour eux et tant mieux
pour elle mais ça veut dire aussi qu'on
nous continue d'oublier les personnes
qui ont pas accès également à quand même
faire des prouesses de médecine en page
7 agences artificielle avec dans cette
affaire cet aspect internet se traduit
d'abord et avant tout par des frigos
connectés c'est ça la réalité c'est que
c'est une une approche caricaturale de
dire ça se traduit par des frigos
connectés et je disais ça me rappelle la
phrase d'eric yole sûr ça permet de
regarder du porno dans l'ascenseur c'est
hyper restrictif de ce qu'en hd avait
traité les meilleures grimpeuses âge du
les usages du numérique et c'est
effectivement vous l'avez dit c'est la
télémédecine c'est aussi quand vous
reliez davantage de foyers
c'est aussi on est dans une logique un
petit peu avec cette crise est un des
effets notoires de déconcentration vers
peut-être des zones qui était moins
dense et on renvoie à l'instant la la
citation vous en parliez d'eric yole de
mer de de grenoble 1 c'était au grand
jury
c'était c'était des quelques semaines
mais emmanuel macron lui même et pas
caricatural quand il dit en gros et à
les amish d'un côté puis les
progressistes de l'autre je sais pas
s'il faut encore une fois organisé le
débat sous cet angle là ce qui est sûr
c'est que moi je vois un certain nombre
d'opportunités en termes d'innovation en
termes de compétitivité pour nous
embrouiller c'est pas un maigre débat
dans le cadre de cette crise sanitaire
et après les efforts que l'on a fait ces
trois dernières années pour ramener la
france justement dans le numéro un de
notre activité et puis par exemple ça
déploie aussi on a déployé la et
robotique on est maintenant dans le top
3 des pays où il ya le plus de
robotisation nos industries eh bien oui
ça sert aussi à ça la 5g ça sert aussi à
à à rendre nos industries plus
intelligente et à créer davantage
d'emplois industriels en france donc je
crois que bien sûr il y à ce débat de l'
usage personnel mais comme vous disiez
l'instant chacun en fait son propre
usage mais il faut je crois à essayer de
voir un peu plus l'image globale est de
se dire que ça offre des opportunités
de progrès pour un certain nombre de
secteurs
merci beaucoup merci à vous j'espère
qu'on y voit un peu plus clair que
chacun a pu se forger une opinion en
tout cas pour l'instant les points de
vue des deux côtés de ce plateau sont
plutôt irréconciliables pourquoi est ce
qu'il fallait faire maintenant plutôt
que dans trois mois mais à part ça tout
va bien en tout cas le pari de baic a
essayé de vous répondre je vous avoue
michel combeau julien bayou vous restez
avec nous on va parler un petit peu de
votre actualité à présent les échéances
électorales à venir
la stratégie de votre parti c'est la
séquence du grand témoin 38
[Musique]
julien bayou on a cru un temps un petit
temps qu'une candidature d'union de la
gauche serait possible c'est évidemment
raté la meilleure preuve c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui s'est déclarée il n'a pas
attendu de savoir exactement ce que
pense l ensemble des ténors de la gauche
il est allé ou écouter ce qu'on a dit
celui qui pourrait porter vos couleurs
en 2022 y aller que satan il y incarne
une pensée politique il incarne un
logiciel politique qui elle vous regarde
un mouvement politique qui n'est pas le
mien
il ya une clarification jean luc
mélenchon va être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
c'est une surprise pour personne ça
clarifie le paysage politique et puis ça
clarifie aussi encore pourcel et pour
ceux qui considéraient que l'alliance
avec jean luc mélenchon était une étape
indispensable de la victoire de 2022 moi
je suis pas pour remplacer un dirigisme
d'état technocratique libéral par un
dirigisme d'état rouge et vert voilà pas
de rouge et vert du rose et du verre
c'est envisageable ou pas en fait
excuser moi même vous raisonnez toujours
un peu à l'ancienne
nous nous disons je pose voyez-vous le
raisonner sur l'alliance des anciens
partis nous nous disons priorité l
écologie environnement justice sociale
démocratie des terrains qui ont été
l'objet de terribles renoncement
même de trahison à partir des manuels
macron et c'est ce qu'on nous avons
porté aux municipales l'écologie est
avec des configurations assez différente
selon les selon les endroits
mais toujours avec un point commun
l'écologie et je peux constater que ça
plutôt bien fonctionné puisqu'on a eu
des succès historiques à strasbourg à
lyon à tours à bordeaux à grenoble et
souvent face à l air eux-mêmes qui en
fait en guise de projet choisissez
l'alliance anti climat choisissez faire
la nuance avec la droite donc de plus en
plus dans la politique c'est en marx on
l'entend mais ça nous empêche pas
d'avoir quelques quelques alliés il y en
a eu à paris notamment aux municipales
questions sur mélenchon l'a vu le drone
avec la bougie s'impose dans le champ
politique comme un projet en soi
vous avez l'extrême droite vous avez une
sorte d'alliance des droites
lr alejo mc2 d'ailleurs assez magistrale
sur la loi sécurité globale en fait et
la relève macron promettait une
révolution démocratique c'est finalement
une gestion assez autoritaire est là et
l'écologie qui ne crois pas être un
projet fédérateur pour le pays et qu'on
attribue cette un besoin de protection
d'environnement de justice sociale la
manière dont vous voyez les nouveaux
clivages
erik cole s'est affichée avec les
insoumis l'été dernier alors université
d'été si c'est une hypothèse
si yannick jadot et des désignés à la
primaire y aurait qu un transfert tout
le monde serait derrière lui dans votre
partie parce qu'on a l'impression
parfois il ya deux lignes et pour moi je
ne sais pas si c'est vous prenez vos
désirs pour des réalités
mini dément excusez moi moi je suis
écologiste nous sommes écologistes
environnement justice sociale démocratie
dans notre conception dans notre
logiciel
il ya vraiment un alignement et tagliani
jadot qui eric piolle qui doit citer
sandrine rousseau qui est également
candidate à la primaire
nous aurons notre calendrier nous
désignerons notre candidature à l'été
prochain et ensuite nous proposons de
construire une coalition à vocation
majoritaire dont je me souviens pas de
lit
parfois irréconciliables je pense au
sujet de la laïcité notamment tout est
parfaitement clair sur ces sur ces
sujets là par exemple sur la laïcité
la loi de 1905 toute la loi 1905 cessons
de le répéter le droit à la caricature
fait partie de la liberté d'expression
c'est un principe intangible j'ai eu
l'occasion de réaffirmer mon soutien à
la pauvre milla adolescente milla qui
fait l'objet de menaces de mort pour
pour le sujet c'est non négociable
ségolène royal vous l'avez peut-être
écouté récemment non
elle s'est exprimée sur les caricatures
en expliquant qu'elle l'ait trouvé
insultantes et qu'elle était je venais
heurté le principe de la fraternité
n'est pas entendue non je fais le
confrère de seignosse et moulins pas de
commentaire donc sur l'économie le
marché attend quand yannick jadot
explique que la transition se fera avec
les entreprises ou ne sera pas là encore
vous êtes tous d'accord chez les verts
et nous nous disons l'enjeu c'est de
questionner la finalité de l'économie
c'est-à-dire qu'on depuis je suis né
-1980 grosso modo il s'agit un peu comme
le disait marie lebey qu'il s'agit
d'avantagé les entreprises parce que
forcément il n'en finira du bon
aujourd'hui on a 10 millions de pauvres
des millions de chômeurs une perte de
sens aussi au travail et des entreprises
qui font des profits et qui licencient
dans le même temps tout en empochant des
aides publiques
donc ça nous disons ça ça a fait la
preuve de sa carence de sa faillite et
l'enjeu c'est de subordonner l'économie
à la recherche du bien commun la
protection de l'environnement la justice
sociale donc par exemple nous n'aurions
pas fait le cic eux depuis 2014
le crédit impôt compétitif même avec des
contreparties mais par contre nous
aurions mis des contreparties
ça se peut pas dire ne pas le faire ça
veut dire le faire mais cela dit d'un
ton compétitivité emploi ça et des
baisses de charges pour les supermarchés
des cotisations ces avantages les
supermarchés plutôt que le petit
commerce
est ce un avantage amazon plutôt que les
libraires nous nous décidons de choisir
ce qui est utile au bien commun et
notamment les pme
je prends un exemple il ya un tiers des
lycées en ile-de-france qui sont
vétustes très mauvais pour les lycéens
en particulier en période de crise
sanitaire
et quand valérie pécresse la présidente
de région veut les faire rénover elle
confie tout ça à 20,6 à eiffage
et s'attarde donc l'enjeu c'est
d'accélérer parce que c'est un enjeu
c'est bon pour le climat c'est bon pour
la santé mais c'est de l'état il doit
faire et de décidé de privilégier les
petites entreprises les petites
entreprises pas forcément acte pas
forcément le fait de réaliser vous savez
tout à l'heure je discutais d'un
protectionnisme vert voilà ce que nous
portons et donc ben yannick jadot parle
plus de protectionnisme vert aux
frontières européennes c'est son rôle il
les partage parlementaires européens
eric piolle va plus insisté sur la
rénovation thermique
porté par le tissu économique local
autour de grenoble c'est oui parfois on
al'impression la décroissance c'est pas
un mot tabou pour elle est ce que ça
c'est compatible avec yannick jadot qui
lui veut vraiment on sent rester dans
les connaissances excusez moi parce que
quand il ya un accident de pollution ça
fait la croissance est ce que c'est
souhaitable si vous me parlez de la
croissance du nombre de libraires ou des
indicateurs de bien-être c'est aussi
pour ça que nous voulons je le disais
subordonnés l'économie au bien-être et
donc notamment questionné ces
indicateurs de richesse c'est la loi et
face à ce qui est aujourd'hui porte
parole de notre mouvement qui disait
plutôt que le pibe est donc là
producteurs production de richesses
indifférenciée choisir ma part ample et
l'indicateur de développement humain sur
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé par
ici d'un débat qui existe depuis depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs beaucoup beaucoup
de portes
il est poussé d'ailleurs dans dans
plusieurs dans plusieurs pays yannick
jadot il est prêt à reprendre toutes ces
idées si c'était c'était lui puisque
c'est vrai que en termes de notoriété et
on a parfois l'impression au terme de
deux désireux d'y aller pour pour 2022
il semble il semble celui qui chaque
chose en son temps c'est à nous d'abord
la priorité c'est la crise sanitaire et
ses effets il ya une absence je croyais
à un impensé de la part du gouvernement
sur la vulnérabilité notre pays sur les
crises sociales qui viennent je pense à
toutes ces personnes dépendantes qui
sont au bord de basculer dans la misère
il ya zéro vraiment un plan de relance
qui qui prend en compte des mesures de
lutte contre la pauvreté par exemple le
rsa pour les moins de 25 ans ensuite
viendra le temps des régionales et
départementales
je suis candidat en ile-de-france pour
la faire de cette région le
de lance de la transition écolo ça peut
créer des emplois un million d'emplois
au niveau national et puis ensuite nous
aurons la désignation pour la
candidature on à ce stade trois
candidats et candidates peut-être
peut-être un peu plus demain nous
trancherons nous nous croient distrait
après les régionales après les
régionales donc après cet été que je
suis un simple les adhérents les
calendriers les régionales vont voter
nous on croit on croit fermement que
c'est en étant convaincants qu'on peut
rassembler je pense vraiment que c'est
l'écologie qui peut fédérer salon on a
fait un référé liberté pour permettre un
égal accès à la nature aujourd'hui on
est limité dans le cadre du 1 km et il
ya beaucoup de gens qui malheureusement
dans ce 1 km ont pas accès à la nature à
des parcs et jardins de taille
suffisante supprimé pour wii elle doit
être en tout cas modifié pour permettre
un accès un égal accès à la nature nous
nous disons les jardins publics sont les
jardins de ceux qui n'en ont pas et ça
donc c'est le lien envoyer entre
environnement et justice sociale plus
d'écologie c'est plus de justice tout
simplement un mot sur la crise sanitaire
le déconfinement l'a compris sera
progressif c'est ce qu'a martelé hier
jean castex à l'assemblée nationale
premières lueurs d'espoir plusieurs
laboratoires pharmaceutiques promettent
on met mais ont mis au point un vaccin
qui est en bonne voie de de validation
la campagne vaccinale va commencer début
janvier
c'est ce qu'affirme le gouvernement soit
il le rendre obligatoire ce vaccin pour
l'instant c'est peut-être prématuré on a
pas encore de vaccin c'est vrai que vous
vous le dit c'est une lueur d'espoir
séverine exado y est favorable
pour l'instant il ya un enjeu de
logistique de ce que j'ai compris ce
message des 12es ce que si on les a si
on allait d'eau si on a la logistique
s'ils s'avèrent est sain et sûr toute la
population française doit être avec des
collations ce n'est pas le cas mais
c'est ma question voulez-vous répondre à
l'enjeu
non nous sommes bien sûr pour le
principe de vaccination obligatoire je
vais vous dire il ya un enjeu de
adhésion vaccinale est d'abord et en
premier lieu de logistique s'il ya un
sujet de nombre de doses je ne suis pas
à moi expert en la matière je m'en
référerai aux préconisations des agences
sanitaires au niveau européenne et
française est semble-t-il peut-être vous
privilégiez les professionnels de santé
ou les personnes vulnérables anti vaccin
qui est puissant en france on le voit
dans les enquêtes d'opinion est il
dangereux
oui clairement oui je pense qu'il ya un
enjeu alors il ya un enjeu de
transparence dans ces sujets je pense
que l'enjeu c'est la transparence pour
couper court en cl les vampires ont
horreur de la lumière
il faut couper court à tous les complots
c'est pour ça que l'action par exemple
de david cormand au niveau européen est
utile il a obtenu que les contrats que
va passer la commission européenne avec
les labos pharmaceutiques soit rendue
publique
voilà comme ça il n'y a pas de
spéculation sur qui profitent de quoi
ces publics c'est normal celle intime
c'est notre santé
ça doit être la transparence qui prévaut
mais oui c'est ces mouvements sont
dangereux tout simplement parce que on a
besoin d'une couverture vaccinale sur
bon nombre de maladies une couverture
vaccinale importante quand moi je me
vaccine pas finalement je me mets en
danger
on pourrait dire c'est ma responsabilité
c'est ma liberté mais c'est pas vrai
parce que je vous met également en
danger en risquant de favoriser d'autres
maladies et on va suivre évidemment ces
vaccins leur leur mise au point leur
validation et la manière dont ils seront
proposés aux français vous restez avec
nous julien bayou c'est l'heure de la
chronique de thomas des prêts comme
chaque soir il nous raconte sa journée à
l'assemblée ce soit une affaire d'accent
oui exactement myriam c'est la
proposition de loi dont tout le monde a
parlé aujourd'hui promouvoir la france
des accents voilà son objectif mais à
quoi va-t-elle vraiment servir joueurs
[Musique]
alors on a tous un accent vous moi au
nord au sud à l'est à l'ouest dans les
outre-mers encore ce bref tous les
français ont un accent mais est ce qu'on
s'est un peu moins c'est que cet accent
et parfois motif de discrimination et ce
à un député du groupe agir ensemble ne
le veut plus il a décidé d'inscrire dans
la loi la discrimination pour les
accents sa proposition était débattue ce
matin en commission des lois
on est allé le rencontrer bonjour
monsieur le député c'est vous qui
portait cette proposition pour la france
des accents ça veut dire quoi
en effet je porte une proposition qui
vise à essayer de faire en sorte que
dans notre pays on discrimine au moins
par l'accent c'est à dire que le fait
qu'on vienne d'une région d'une
condition sociale particulière à partir
du moment où on maîtrise le français
comme tout le monde ne soit pas
préjudiciable
mais est ce que ceux qui font des
blagues sur les accents qui se moque des
belges des gens du sud des gens du nord
des gens viennent d'alsace ça veut dire
que demain ils pourront plus faire de
blagues
d'abord nous avons tous nous avons tous
un accent pour l'autre il faut déjà
avoir ça à voir ça l'esprit qui n'ont
pas du tout l'objet c'est pas 2 c'est
pas de pénaliser des sons à la
répression c'est juste d'essayer de deux
dvi un petit peu les consciences et de
faire évoluer les mentalités s'agit pas
de mettre tout le monde en prison c'est
pas du tout l'objet de la proposition de
loi il s'agit de faire avancer les
choses de façon à ce qu'elle évolue
comme on l'a fait pour d'autres
discriminations le statut de la femme a
beaucoup évolué en sentant de
l'homosexualité de la couleur de peau
des convictions religieuses
on avait deux grands acteurs de grands
comédiens des personnalités publiques
avec des accents il ya quelques années
elle a pratiquement plus aujourd'hui
mais en emprunts ministre en axant
maintenant on a un premier ministre qui
est l'accent que vous avez vu que son
arrivée a été extrêmement commenté on
n'a pas commenté son parcours où son
coeur chiffres là commenté son accent je
trouve que c'est quand même très
réducteur
venant de quelqu'un qui a occupé occupé
la plupart des fonctions les plus nobles
haut niveau de l'état
alors il paraît que l'assemblée
nationale est le reflet de la population
française alors nous on est allé à la
rencontre des députés pour leur demander
si dans la vie il avait déjà été
discriminée à cause de leurs actions un
jour j'étais deuxième colloque est en
fait le journaliste qui nous interviewer
ne comprenait pas ce que je disais on
est exposé à sciences po les petits
collègues et mon prof c'était marrer
parce que je dise
avéo lieu d'avec et si au lieu de tu as
donc ça n'avait marqué en alsace à la
fin du mauvais on prononce le thé parce
que le 8 ne se prononcent pas tout à
fait de la même façon que dans d'autres
territoires oui oui bon c'est des
taquineries mais c'est des taquineries
qui font aussi la richesse de nos
rencontres de nos échanges
ici à l'assemblée quand on pense à
député qui a un accent pense forcément à
vous jean lassalle vous avez pensé sur
les ksour 10 vous me posez la question
je vous dis oui s'il s'agit le barça
mais rebelle rarement pour parler
d'autres sujets souvent quand on
s'exprime avec un accent un peu comme le
mien un peu de la terre un peu du
terroir et bien on n'est pas forcément
pris au sérieux et donc je trouve ça
particulièrement désagréable que
l'accent est influent sur ce que l'on
dit voilà même et pour être tout à fait
complet cette proposition de loi pour
promouvoir la france des accents sera
débattu la semaine prochaine dans
l'hémicycle
nous serons le 26 nov et nous y serons
merci thomas on va parler à présent de
ce débat tendu dans l'hémicycle sur la
proposition de loi dite sécurité globale
tension dans l'hémicycle hier soir et
tension surtout à l'extérieur du palais
bourbon la manifestation contre
l'article 24 de ce texte a dégénéré on
en parle tout de suite avec nos invités
[Musique]
bonsoir avec paul biya
merci d'être là vous êtes député en
marche de gironde et vous défendez
l'article 24 de ce texte notamment un
qui vise à interdire à certaines
conditions la diffusion d'image de
policiers en eau pas en opération julien
bayou et contre ce texte contre
l'article 24 d'abord les images de cette
manifestation d'hier soir sur fond de
débat musclé dans l'hémicycle récit
signé elsa monde un gala syndicats de
journalistes ligue des droits de l'homme
avocats tous ont manifesté devant
l'assemblée nationale
dans leur collimateur la proposition de
loi pour une sécurité globale et son
article 24 il puni d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amendé le fait de diffuser par
quelques moyen que ce soit et quel qu'en
soit le support
dans le but qu'il soit porté atteinte à
son intégrité physique ou psychique
l'image du visage ou tout autre élément
d'identification d'un agent de la police
nationale ou de la gendarmerie
nationales pour l'opposition à gauche
cette mesure pourrait empêcher demain le
travail des journalistes et le contrôle
des citoyens des députés socialistes et
insoumis se sont joints aux manifestants
avant de défendre leurs positions dans
l'hémicycle le principe de sûreté tel
que l'entend républicain est globale et
commence par la liberté fondamentale de
contrôler ceux qui exercent le pouvoir
c'est donc un droit absolu de 2,6 les
éparses et signe de contrôler comment
est utilisé la force
l'ambiance est tendue cessé de lui
relève matt lui devrait jamais si vous
perdez votre temps
monsieur le ministre et lui seul a la
parole le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin répond vous expliquer désormais
que plus personne ne pourra rien filmé
monsieur le président mélenchon ayons
des débats de fond mais relisez
l'article 24 je vous en supplie les
journalistes pourront filmer les
citoyens pourront filmer ce que nous
souhaitons pas assez les appels au
meurtre
on a peut-être une différence sur ce
point mais des bâtons si normalement en
lisant le texte met des doutes il n'y en
a pas que sur les bancs des oppositions
l'allier modem fait part de ses grandes
réserves
enfin mes chers collègues et
heureusement nos forces de l'ordre en
cas d'agression ou de harcèlement sont
aujourd'hui déjà protégée par les
dispositions en vigueur du code pénal et
par la loi de 1881 sur la presse le
groupe modem et ses 56 membres
décideront de leurs votes à l'issue des
débats était voilà et cette
manifestation s'est terminée vous allez
le voir par des échauffourées des heures
vous le voyez qui ont clé éclaté à la
fin du rassemblement des policiers qui
ont fait usage de canons à eau de gaz
lacrymogènes pour disperser les
manifestants parmi lesquels figuraient
donc de nombreux jeunes qui ont détruit
vous le voyez du mobilier urbain
ce matin préfecture de police de paris a
fait un bilan
trente trois interpellations dix blessés
légers dont neuf parmi les forces de
l'ordre
éric pouliot quand vous voyez ce que ça
génère cet article 24
quand vous voyez ce rassemblement cette
tension
vous dites pas au fond est ce que le jeu
en vaut la chandelle
franchement ce que je me dis surtout
c'est que ce que ça génère c'est pas
l'article 24 qui le génère c'est ce que
les gens disent de l'article 24 qui
génére ça c'est quand je vois des unes
de presse quasi intolérable qui disent
que c'était une atteinte à la liberté de
la presse qui sert qui complètement
contredisent ou font de la
désinformation alors que le journalisme
normalement est un métier qu'il ya une
déontologie dire que cet article 20 4
serait liberticide ou portent atteinte à
y passer de la presse est faux expliquez
nous en quoi je vous pose une question
je suis journal et je suis dans une
manipulation
je sais que je peux encourir un an de
prison 45000 euros d'amendé si je filme
et que je diffuse par exemple en direct
dans les normands médias mais tant que
je travaille dans une chaîne
d'information cela m'est arrivé en
continu par le passé je n'ai pas le
temps de proposer le flottage on vous
demande pas de foot et donc ces images
oui je peux les diffuser tout à fait
très bien et si en face à cause de cet
article de loi
un policier me dit vous n'avez pas le
droit vous n'avez pas le droit c'est pas
vrai vous avez le droit
oui mais vous ne craignez pas qu'à ce
moment là le journaliste face à la force
de l'ordre et ex sa caméra mais ça le
risque d' auto-censure alors le sait pas
au législateur de gérer l'autocensure de
profession fait l'application d'un texte
sur le terrain je suis inquiété parce
que vous avez toujours raison contre
tout le monde
la défenseur des droits claire hédon a
dit attention attention attention vie
privée liberté d'expression liberté de
réunion et elle met du logiciel par le
haut que le haut conseil consultatif aux
droits de l'homme à l'onu dit attention
attention liberté d'expression les
magistrats les avocats
bien sûr la ligue des droits de l'homme
bien sûr les écologistes disent
attention
dharmanand les ministres intérieur
lui-même il ya deux semaines disait
l'objectif est d'empêcher la diffusion
aujourd'hui vous avez rétropédaler vos
meilleurs alliés du modem 10
la rédaction a requis 24 darmanin les
ministères musée langue ils seraient 10
kg ou morale du touch this year
excusez moi c'est quand même le mur
intérieur qui malheureusement décide il
me semble malheureusement si j'avais
permanent a dit les images seront
interdites de diffusion
il a eu tort d'aller jusque là je sais
pas moi à dire ce que doit dire un
ministre ce que je dis c'est que je suis
législateur je vote des textes de loi je
veux vous parler que de ce qu'il ya dans
le texte de loi et dans le texte de loi
il n'a jamais été dit le mot de floutage
là j'ai personnellement fait aussi de la
politique vous en faites aussi je pense
que la vie mon avis personnel sur
général dames 1
pourquoi pourquoi at il dit à un moment
c'est vrai c'est un député qui ne peut
pas nous ayons c'est un avis personnel
cypher piscine qui ne peut pas donner
sens à 10 heures se sait bien que
réputés je le répète ça c'est vraiment
terrible ans si vous voulez mais non
mais c'est comme ça qu'on vous écoute
vous avez la parole
voilà chez tata que les propos
diffamants wells eu le temps on peut un
peu mais c'est ce que vous faites là
actuellement mon endroit locales à
utiliser juste et j'espère donc que s'il
voulait devant les tribunaux moi je
rédige une tribune qui donne son avis
qu'il y avait à un moment peut-être que
gérald darmanin est revenu sur ses
propos mais deux lignes au fond vous
vous étiez contre la ligne de gérald
darmanin
nous on a toujours été pour protéger les
policiers quand ils sont victimes
comptaient d appel au viol de policières
sur les réseaux sociaux
quand on a des policiers qui nous disent
qu'ils mettent leurs enfants dans le
privé et dans le département d'un côté
parce que ils se font casser la gueule
parce qu'ils sont fils de flic moi ça ça
c'est quelque chose que je ne peux pas
accepter en or et public
donc je pense qu'on a une à devoir de
protéger mes skis veut pas dire que on a
un devoir d'accepter les fautes
professionnelles les débordements et
c'est donc bien sûr que on peut filmer
ces images qui ont pu lancer des alertes
je pense à la sphère chouïa évidemment
mais pas de problème ces images n'y
avait pas de tension avec ce texte la
bonne anna existe tout cas je vous donne
la parole j'ai beaucoup parlé
pardonnez-moi mais j'aimerais quand même
et je vous la donne après julien bayou
vous faire entendre vos collègues de la
majorité parce que manifestement erwan
balanant bonsoir vous êtes député modem
du finistère manifestement il ya un
petit malaise au sein de la majorité
pour ne pas dire un véritable malaise
sur cet article
24 vous êtes alliés 1 du groupe
majoritaire et vous devez rédiger un
amendement de suppression de cet article
24 pour quelles raisons bon tout
simplement parce que nous pensons qu'il
atteint un certain nombre d' équilibre
mais juste je voudrais revenir sur ce
que je viens d'entendre le débat que je
viens d'entendre sur cet article il faut
être extrêmement sérieux et je suis
désolé
même si on est en accord sur l'
opposition à ce texte j'ai entendu des
choses qui n'était pas vraiment sérieuse
de la part de monsieur bayou quand
monsieur bayou dit
à l'instant il a dit des choses qui sont
pas vraies je vais pas refaire la liste
enfin une fois être il faut être
extrêmement sérieux sur cette longue six
mois sur quoi jeter à l'eau eh bien vous
avez faux sur le fait que oui l'article
ne dit pas qu'on interdit de filmer et
le ministre de l'intérieur l'a dit
pourtant oui mais c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur et justement c'est là que
vous dites un peu n'importe quoi
monsieur bayou il ya une différence
entre le ministre de l'intérieur et les
parlementaires mais doté et qu'ils
attendent et je vous ai pas couper si
vous connaissiez précisément dit excusez
moi est ce que je me disais non je vous
pose cette question n'a pas de prix on a
compris votre bémol entre les propos du
ministre de l'intérieur et l'article de
textes poétiques de loi sauf que vous au
modèle pardonnez moi mais vous demandez
ce que cet article soit supprimé oui
c'est bien ça oui quoi alors pourquoi
pour plusieurs raisons déjà première
raison je pense et nous pensons dans le
groupe modem qu' il ya déjà un arsenal
législatif qui existe entre la loi de
1881 et le code pénal qui protège les
policiers maintenant est-ce qu'il faut
peut-être le renforcer oui pourquoi pas
c'est une c'est le premier sujet le
deuxième par contre le problème qui nous
qui est posée par ce texte et pas dans
ce texte
et c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut le
faire à notre sens premièrement ça doit
être sujet d'un vrai débat de société
sur le rapport que l'on a à l'image aux
policiers à la façon dont on se comporte
dans une manifestation aujourd'hui on
est en train de je suis un peu en colère
parce que les opposants sont en train de
faire en sorte que ce texte va passer
alors qu'il doit pas passer bon bref
attendez attendez attendez
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
exactement vous êtes passé c'était de
voter ce texte est finalement non moi je
veux moi je m'opposerai à cet article
tel qu'il est rédigé tout simplement
parce que il n'est pas il touche un
certain nombre d' équilibre et en plus
il met du trouble on le voit il ya un
certain nombre de deux journalistes
qu'ils sont troublés et moi en tant qu
ancien photographe et en tant qu ancien
reporter d'image
j'avoue que je suis extrêmement troublée
et j'ai regardé les milliers d'image que
j'ai fait de manifestations est certaine
oui je me dis ah peut-être que celle là
je les aurais pas diffusé donc c'est là
qu'il ya un vrai sujet et c'est là qu'il
faut améliorer les choses sur ce texte
est la difficulté c'est aussi la méthode
on est sur une ppl
finalement qui avait position de loi
voilà une proposition de loi avec un
très bon travail qui a été fait par
fauvergue tour au sur tout un aspect le
continuum de sécurité tout ça a été très
bien fait et il ya eu des choses qui ont
été rajoutés par équipes a requis 24
qu'il a rajouté wii qui a été rajoutée
par ministre de l'intérieur il sait pas
oui mais c'est là monsieur bayou que
vous pouvez pas laisser dire à mon
collègue vous pouvez le pas lui dire
qu'il a le droit d'être en accord avec
le ministre de l'intérieur a demandé son
avis les haies et moi j'ai le droit
d'être en opposition et tous ces sujets
là c'est le salaire c'est très clair
merci merci on va donner le droit de
réponse maintenant alors à julien bayou
et monsieur paul biya
merci erwan balanant merci beaucoup
alors d'abord pour dire que moi j'ai le
plus au respect pour la fonction de
parlementaire et c'est pour ça que je
m'attriste quentin député me dit je ne
veux pas donner mon avis voilà ce que je
suis malade un monsieur ballon
monsieur baladins exprime son opinion
son intime conviction et c'est ça que
j'attends maintenant parlementaire même
si j'ai pas voté pour le voyez ça c'est
extrêmement et un amendement de
suppression d'un article
quand on est dans le même groupe dans la
majorité il dira je disais n'importe
quoi je réitère le ministre de
l'intérieur a bien dit il ya deux
semaines qu'ils voulaient pas claire
parce que maintenant on va se concentrer
sur son nom à lévis mais je voudrais en
crise voudrait répond à notre détecter
un enjeu de protection des policiers et
des policières
oui il ya des personnes qui harcèlent
les policiers les policières en ligne ou
en physique
cette proposition de loi ne résoudra
rien nous nous recommandons de mettre
des moyens humains
nous demandons des moyens humains pour
la police nationale ce sont les maires
écologistes qui le réclament
ça a été une longue bataille à grenoble
pour obtenir 13 policiers en plus six
ans d'attentes précises et un
accompagnement oui bien sûr il ya besoin
on a besoin de plus effective récapitule
tout aussi on a besoin de sécurité et
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
mais pour répondre à la question du
harcèlement spécifique des policiers
pour véritablement les protéger un des
moyens pour pharos la plate forme de
signalement en ligne et de un
accompagnement accompagnant les pour
porter plainte et sanctionnés alors
pharos le serbe réprimer ces personnes
qui la leur et rigaudiat vous allez
avoir un droit de réponse mais il ya une
une vraie objections qui vous est posée
notamment par vos alliés modem et qu'on
retrouve chez des opposants ce texte
c'est que au fond l'arsenal juridique
existe déjà
les menaces de mort c'est une infraction
pénale c'est un délit le cyber
harcèlement
c'est un délit il y avait il besoin d'un
article de loi dont on ne sait même pas
s'il ne va pas être censurée par le
conseil constitutionnel pour pour
garantir la protection des policiers
je vois pas pourquoi il serait censurée
et je vais commenter je vous remercie de
nous ramener sur le fond du texte parce
que là où je vais très clair pas de
protection des policiers s'étaient pas
le fond du ténor mais là où je vais très
claire par rapport à pourquoi vous me
faites dire ce que je vais peut être
aller on essaye de rester concentré
c'est que justement je suis pas là pour
commenter les commentaires des uns et
des autres donc je pars avoir parlé de
ce texte donc effectivement pourquoi il
n'avait besoin parce que je pense qu'il
est important de caractériser
l'intention les usages ont évolué avec
le temps on voit bien que les moyens on
évolue aussi
aujourd'hui on est face à des
comportements des pratiques vidéo sur
internet avec pourquoi même aussi des
fois des images détournées et c'est de
la manipulation d'image 2d vidéos qui
sont pas exacts qui sont des fois pas
contextualiser etc ce sont des vieilles
vidéos qui sont exposées dans d'autres
pays
cet article va dissuader les intentions
malveillantes elle va de s'en prendre
l'arrêté en panne hier une longueur de
plus hier un journaliste est à empêcher
de couvrir la manifestation et le droit
d'information 3 d'information est sacrée
et maltraités vous le défendez ont
laissé six mais je voudrais qu'on
termine en allant voir l amont d'un
gamin qui nous attend depuis la salle
des quatre colonnes va falloir faire
vite ma chère exactes et les l'avenir au
fond de cet article 24
si controversé est ce qu'il va être
adopté est ce qu'il va être réécrit ou
est ce qu'il va être rejetée eh bien
écoutez pour l'instant myriam ce n'est
absolument pas à trancher un pilier de
la majorité me disait on va attendre
d'être au pied du mur et puis on va
décider il ya plusieurs scénarios
évidemment tout le monde dans la
majorité voit bien que
les autour de cet article alors on peut
le réécrire on peut essayer de le
réécrire mais il faut encore que le
gouvernement soit d'accord c'est un
article a déjà trouvé un équilibre
puisque gérald darmanin voulait aller
plus loin patients que le gouvernement
accepte donc on leur ai écrit alors on
sort la calculette
on voit si on peut obtenir la majorité
le groupe la république en marche seul
ne peut pas l'avoir et il y aura en plus
des députés qui voteront contre cet
article on va prendre les voix d'agir
ensemble on va regarder mais le modem
est un peu divisé donc sinon on comptera
sur les voix de la droite et tant pis
emmanuel macron veut faire des sujets
régaliens l'importance de fin de ce1 de
son mandat et donc la droite viendra
compléter les bras merci beaucoup elsa
c'est une stratégie un peu plus globale
que ça qui est en train de se mettre en
oeuvre au sommet de l'état non eric
polliat dans la perspective de 2022
président parle à la droite non je crois
que c'est surtout qu'on parle de
sécurité et que la sécurité ça l'enjeu
majeur dans les années qui arrivent et
bien évidemment on voit que nous sommes
confrontés à différentes niveaux une
menace on voit bien que c'est un sujet
qui préoccupe les français on voit bien
que il faut à des réponses donc nous y
répondons après nous y répondons avec
ceux qui ont envie d'y répondre avec
nous merci de la fin grand témoin un
sujet majeur comme ça la protection de
policiers ou de la liberté d'expression
et réduit un enjeu de communication
politique
rien dans ce texte ne résout la question
de la sécurité de nos policiers nos
policière on a besoin de moyens humains
sur le terrain on a besoin d accompagner
pour porter plainte
et là on va piétiner la liberté
d'expression encore une fois la
journaliste nous disent qu'ils ont du
mal à couvrir de plus en plus les
manifestations et le ministre intérieur
veut aller toujours plus loin on va
suivre ce débat attentivement article 24
qui devrait être discutée demain dans la
soirée peut-être ou après demain ou
après demain nous verrons merci
messieurs merci d'avoir été notre grand
témoin julien bayou merci à vous
monsieur le député c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve demain même lieu
même heure
très belle soirée à vous
[Musique]